[Musique]
la rue libanaise peut crier victoire
le premier ministre saad hariri a
finalement jeté l'épongé
je vais présenter la démission de mon
gouvernement au président michel aoun at
il dit en ajoutant que tous les acteurs
politiques libanais doivent maintenant
veiller à protéger le pays paralysé
depuis près de deux semaines le liban
vit une situation sans précédent en 76
ans d'histoire les manifestants exigent
non seulement la démission du
gouvernement
mais aussi la fin de la corruption la
restructuration de l'économie et la
déconfessionnalisation de la vie
politique
la démission de hariri c'est la première
étape dans la construction d'un pays
démocratique la première victoire dit ce
manifestant
maintenant nous devons commencer à
penser à une seconde étape un taux de
chômage chez les jeunes qui frise les 40
%
un quart de la population qui vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté
le liban est parmi les pays les plus
inégalitaires au monde et parmi les plus
endettés infrastructures déficientes
coupure constante d'électricité et d'eau
les libanais en non tu as et pardonne à
les religions qui les ont souvent
séparés ils se sont donné la main chaque
fois que vous avez un million de
millions de personnes dans la rue c'est
une façon de mesurer sa force
or je vous rappelle libanais ces quatre
millions de personnes
je vous laisse imaginer le ratio de 30 %
de la population par exemple canadienne
qui s'exprime dans la rue je pense qu'il
n'y a aucune
aucun gouvernement qui tiendrait plus de
cinq minutes
mais le pays qui a connu une guerre
civile longue de 15 ans n'est pas à
l'abri d'une explosion de violence des
partisans du hezbollah chiite se sont
attaqués violemment aux manifestants
un avant-goût du chaos qui pourrait
s'installer les pays voisins comme
l'iran et l'arabie saoudite qui
considère le liban comme un pion de leur
jeu politique régionale pourrait y
trouver leur compte mais c'est analystes
restent confiants les manifestants ne
demandent pas la démission pour
l'instant du président de la république
qui lui peut constituer un gouvernement
de transition sous son patronage et
mener à bien toutes les étapes demandé
c'est l'espoir des centaines des
milliers de libanais qui depuis treize
jours non seulement revendiquent des
changements mais celle m
la fraternité
[Musique]
mais
ici alexandre à chaska radio canada
montréal